director Jeremy Sally Hayes third
feature greenroom pits a punk band
trapped in a bar against militarized
skinheads it's a clever spin on the
entrapment thriller where the heroes
must escape and survive the deadly
situation so we thought we'd ask the
director as well as star Anton Yelchin
they would manage to escape from other
famous films in the genre the trash
compactor from Star Wars how would I get
out of that how would you get I think I
would just die best thing about these
movies is like there's something that
saves you well the force yeah so that's
pretty convenient man Star Wars it's all
pretty convenient the panic room from
panic room so a panic room I think you
just hold your ground and roll the dice
hope that someone's going to turn soft
I'd have a not panic room a room where
I'm just not panicking Air Force One in
Air Force One one of our close family
friends is in that movie playing one of
the Russian bad guys by god I'd grip him
by the balls and I throw them all off
that plane just like Harrison Ford does
phone booth from phone booths that's an
easy one whoa cheated I would run away
in a serpentine pattern yes your apt in
the phone only because there's a sniper
I mean oh and it's serpentine pattern me
that sniper could that's what you talk
to deal with the snipers gonna save
someone else right talk about let me get
well agreed the elevator from devil I
would have a great time I mean look if
I'm trapped in an elevator with the
devil I'd make a deal right Oh at any
time to sell your soul than that you
know that men might as well live it up
cuz it could be great to know who the
devil is taking a cell phone
photo of the ocean from open water so
what I do is just die quicker it's very
morbid make it a short film do a few
festivals okay